[Music]
Paris brought up the biggest bombshell
in her new interview with Rolling Stone
she was sexually assaulted by a much
older complete stranger when she was
just 14 quote I don't want to give too
many details it was really hard for me
and at the time I didn't tell anybody
the next year Paris tried to kill
herself by slashing her wrists and
taking 20 motrin pills she'd actually
tried multiple times before and laughs
it all off tattoos now cover the scars
from the suicide attempt as well as the
track marks left from her previous drug
addiction Paris is wearing a bracelet
that Michael Jackson was wearing when he
died a little like rope and Jade king
he'd gotten in Africa
she said it still smells like him she
said that Michael comes to her and her
dreams all the time
jingo the night nearly eight years after
Michael died Harris now says she
believes her dad was murdered and his
death was a setup he told her that might
happen
he believed that people were out to get
him he owned a song catalog was worth
hundreds of millions dollars and he was
concerned that people are trying to get
their hands on it
the 18 year old who's been at Paris
Fashion Week and doing photo shoots also
blames concert promoters for her dad's
downfall saying quote they drained them
dry and work them to death she then
compared the King of Pop to Justin
Bieber Paris talked to Justin Bieber
briefly backstage at a recent tour and
felt he was going through the motions
and looked exhausted and she were that
he was being overworked in the same way
her dad was
[Music]
you